the oldest ballpark in the big leagues
plays host to a pivotal game three of
this year's american league division
series between the al eastern division
champion tampa bay rays and the wild
card winning boston red sox 31 year old
right-hander native faldi his last
appearance is a large part of the reason
why boston has survived to go this far
tuesday in the wild card game against
the yankees pitched into the sixth
inning about just one earned run on a
solo homer struck out eight did not walk
a batter one two
took something off and struck out loud
one god one on one out for meadows
meadows getting his first start of the
post season over one as a pinch hitter
there's a drive we'll head out to right
field run throw back on it and it's gone
and just like that it's two nothing
tampa and it's a two run homer
for austin meadows on the first pitch he
sees
here on the top of the first inning of
the raise take a two-nothing lead at
fenway he's set to go up against kyle
schwarber pitch you swung on and hit in
the air to left center field pretty well
back by the wall and this ball
is gone it made it over the monster over
the jimmy fund lobo and into the seats a
lead off home run by kyle schwarber and
just like that the raise lead is cut in
half first leadoff batter to homer by a
boston red sox player in the postseason
since dustin pedroia in game one of the
2007 world series two to one tampa as
randy arose arena leads things off
anna
waves and misses all four outs for a
baldy via the strikeout so one out one
on and here's mike cenino
got it finally native baldy says it took
11 pitches to strike out mike zanino
five outs recorded by nate divaldi all
five on swinging strikeouts one two run
it goes swing and a miss strike three
got him on another splitter well he's
had a good one today six punch outs over
two innings for nathan of aldi brandon
leads things off and the visitors half
of ending number three
lau puts it in play schwarber oh wonky
toss
yikes that's going to go down as an
error on kyle schwarber as we mentioned
earlier kyle's still learning the
position and there are two down here in
the third swing and a miss a high
fastball cruise goes down swinging for
the second time and ivaldi is fanned
seven in the first three inning runners
at the corners and nobody out [ __ ]
hernandez he's got hits in five straight
played appearances
that one's gonna get down another base
hit for [ __ ] hernandez and boston has
tied it at two
six straight hits now for kk hernandez
and that's gonna be off for drew
rasmussen enter left-hander josh fleming
two one none out devers up
back up the middle and throw a fourth
straight base hit they're gonna wave
schwarber around
throw to the plates too late boston
takes its first lead of the day
five six seven hitters with a raise down
a run for the first time
two two pitches bounced down to first
[Laughter]
there's the momentum going towards the
picture
he's dipping his gap look at him work in
the room he's having the time of his
life he's like i'm coming towards you
this time and there you go and
here it is
is he a good fit for this team in this
town or
race into the bullpen for their third
reliever of the afternoon he is the
hard-throwing right-hander peter
fairbanks he'll draw [ __ ] hernandez rafi
devers and sandra bogarts [ __ ] is just
on an unbelievable terry
hit a bunch out to left
oh
man
[ __ ] hernandez is the hottest hitter on
the planet how hot is kiki hernandez
424 feet wow he crushed it kiki
hernandez has hits in seven straight at
bats i mean baron mine he had a record
setting friday here's bronco the
dangerous rookie one for three but this
is the time of the night when the rays
feast tampa has a plus 113 run
differential from the seventh inning on
this year that was the best in baseball
franco sends a ball toward the monster
verdugo looks up and it's gone
into the front row of the green monster
juan de franco with his first ever
post-season homer it's a one-run game
4-3 boston so margot third is the tying
run right-hand batter against the
right-hand pitcher
high heat got him two down now the last
chance is randy rosarina here in the
eighth he has struck out swinging twice
and hit a little tapper to the mouth
a rosarina sends out into left center
field that's gonna drop and roll all the
way to the wall the rays have tied it or
rosarina stumbled on his way to second
but still gets in safely with a double
i'm wondering if there was contact with
schwarber between first and second and
randy should be at third sure thought so
i think he should be at third base there
was contact between
schwarber and a rose arena [ __ ] sold out
and tried to save the inning
and the rays who've done this all year
have roared right back to tie the game
and whitlock will go to work on mike
zanino with runners at first and second
and two away
strike three
bottom of the eighth in a 4-4 tie and
the pitch of verdugo line drives center
field charging camera still coming on
dives and makes the catch for out number
one why was that dropping in a hurry
like a cannonball down to the outfield
green and kameyer got the glove
underneath of it and was able to get it
before it could hit the ground nick
pavetta takes over on the mound he was
to be tomorrow's starting pitcher for
boston two out and that'll leave it for
randy a rosarino
runs throw down to second base not close
but margot came off the bag
oh manny margot had that one stolen but
he slid off the bag and i think we're
going to see a replay review on this one
because as we look at the replay it
looks like he might have been able to
jam his left foot back onto the bag
and
for the second straight in and get their
lead off man aboard and here comes kier
meyer there he goes
and
strikes out throw down to second base
third
oh randy's on his way to third where it
was vacant pavetta covers the bag and
rosarina gets back safely wow now
rosarena started to take off for third
and that's when everybody scrambled over
to the bag and they were able to get a
couple of guys there and then randy hit
the brakes went flying back to second
mike cenino's the batter go ahead runs
in scoring position with one away quinn
a miss and a high fastball don goes
zanino
jordan luplow now with two away nevada
delivers strike three call got him on a
curveball what a job by nick pavetta and
he is pumped up as he leaves the field
pavetto with two scoreless innings the
winning run in scoring position with one
god bobby dalbeck has a chance to win it
for the red sox swing and a miss he
struck him out so here is the hottest
hitter [ __ ] hernandez
to shortstop franco backhands it and
gets a perfect one off the first he made
that play look way too easy beautiful
play at both ends wander arranging to
his right and then luplow picking it out
of the dirt and two quick outs here for
pavetta and he could use a limited pitch
counted manuel margot took that next and
there it is swinging a miss for strike
three on a breaking ball down and away
in the raise at the go ahead right
aboard here's kier meyer swinging a
drive deep right field get out of here
get going it is
off the wall it's a double
it's a ground rule double and yandy's
got to go back to third base now did it
hit renfro and go back over the wall
that's the question that's what neal is
saying behind us are going to get
together neal's got a bit of a higher
view than us and said that it hit the
wall and then renfro knocked it over the
wall in which case i believe the umpires
could place the runners i don't know
that i've ever seen this and i don't
know how this i don't know how this
could be
i don't know how it scored and i don't
know how you place the base runner i
know that there is umpire's discretion
that comes into play here all right here
we go
and they're saying it's a double are
they going to put diaz back on base that
is amazing break they are
they'll be talking about this for a long
time nick is ready for the one-two to
zenino here it is and he swings and
misses strike three if they don't score
can you believe it pavetta barking as he
comes off the mound his seventh punch
out they leave two men in scoring
position we go to the bottom of the 13.
so the winning run is on for christian
vasquez there have been seven walk-off
homers by a catcher in postseason
history luis patino delivers and there's
a drive left field high indeed back by
the wall
gone
red sox win it christian vasquez
a two-run homer can you believe it 6-4
boston in 13 innings the wild events of
the top of the 13th
and then christian vasquez is the hero
guy who didn't even start the game in
the lineup
unbelievable game will be talked about
for a long time
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes